[Music]
all right let's go out to
htown and talk to Jason what's up
Jason what's going on Dr John what up
man how we doing all pretty good how are
you good good good what's up brother hey
so um I'm finding myself at 52 pretty
much in complete rebuild mode tell me
about it so the last couple years I uh I
struggled
alcohol I uh lost a really good job I
lost a wife uh during that time I got a
DUI um going through that process
and I right now I'm doing real good I
have been sober eight months almost hey
all right and uh I'm I'm I'm I'm doing
fairly well uh I during that time also I
did not make some uh so good uh
financial decisions y so I'm pretty
much by myself not by myself I have my
children but uh just found myself just
kind of rebuilding and just looking to
uh see or or go through the process of
of of trying to do this and and just to
get in a better place yeah man
dude like I can't tell
you how proud of you I
am thank you I appreciate that well hold
on here like I I'm not just blowing that
off I don't want just to like deflect it
cuz you're good at that You' probably
been deflecting that your whole
life right yeah I'm I'm fairly good at
that you're great at it because you
don't believe it you think I'm lying to
you so here's how I'm not lying to you
um you got hit so
hard actually you're a boxer that got
knocked out Stone knocked
out and that's when most go
dude I'm this is I'm not in for
this and you slowly picked yourself back
up off the
canvas and now you're standing up you're
cleare eyed and you're have one hand on
the top rope and you're thinking about
climbing back in the
ring that is courage brother that is
courage that is
courage and most men quit and you're
not so I'm not blowing smoke at you dude
I'm not blowing smoke at all it's pretty
impressive um so when you say you lost
your wife uh did she leave you or did
she pass away um she left me she left me
okay so you lost a job you lost your
wife you you kind of soft pitched I kind
of struggle with alcohol a little bit
and then I lost everything so I'm
guessing you didn't just kind of
struggle with alcohol a little bit tell
me a little bit about that no not
alcohol has has uh pretty much been a
part of my life uh my adult life how
come then it got it got really just it
was just a norm I know but but most of
us most folks who drink like that that's
the way their bodies figured out how to
not deal with how bad life hurts so why
does life hurt man you know uh I'm still
in that process Dr John I I think I I
struggled a lot as a child
um um um my real dad he uh he really
didn't have anything to do with me and I
was adopted early by the man who I call
my father who
um who adopted me when I was six married
my mother and um not a terrible
childhood but it wasn't it wasn't the
best either but I I never really fit
into I always felt like I never really
fit into his
family and um just struggled with the
acceptance part of
things and um I guess I just dealt with
it in my own ways throughout the years
and and never really addressed it you
know until now you know it just now is
when I'm really really wanting to sit
down and and and and figure out what's
really going on why why I've been that
way so for for so many years I I I can't
answer the whole question but I can get
pretty dang
close
I'm sure you haven't done this but I
hope at some point you
will but I need to go back for just a
second and talk to six-year-old
Jason who is holding the hand of a man
who's not his daddy but a man who's
saying I'll step in the Gap here if it's
what it takes for me to marry your
mama and everyone around you cheering
and you're supposed to be happy about
that yeah and God bless you put food on
the table it never felt like home but at
least you had a roof and you had
food yeah but that six-year-old little
boy is still haunted by that one damning
question which is Daddy what was so bad
about me that you
left yeah he was just he was never there
to begin with that's what I'm saying I
and I didn't I didn't find out who he
actually was till I was like 27 yeah but
he was a ghost he was a ghost
right right exactly but you've got your
own kids right yes four of them did you
walk out on them oh no yeah you can't
even wrap your head around it can
you I know I always been the best dad
but I hold on none of us have none of us
have we've all struggled but listen
don't evade it you can't imagine walking
out on your kid no
no how the hell did your old man walk
out on you yeah
right yes
sir and one magic thing about alcohol is
it plays a pretty good chemical proxy to
connection yeah and so when we're lonely
when our body's screaming at us that
someone's going to leave someone's going
to leave alcohol does make that go away
for a while until it kills us right till
it blows up everything right like I used
to tell people for years the worst part
about alcohol is that
works until it doesn't right exactly
exactly so I'll probably give you
several things I want you to do for
homework at by the time this Call's over
but I want you to write a letter by hand
on notebook paper on a yellowad go to
Walgreens or Walmart or something get a
yellow pad and I want you to write a
letter to six-year-old
Jason and tell that little boy it was
not his
fault
his daddy walked out because something
was wrong with his daddy not him I was a
good kid that deserved to have his old
man around take him to Oilers games and
Astros games even when they were
terrible back
then
right yes sir until you let that little
six-year-old boy stop fighting for
you you're going to always have that Gap
and then you got to deal with you're 56
right 52 how old 52 52 yeah so this part
sucks right at 51 and a half you decided
I'm done I'm getting sober I'm about to
lose I've lost almost everything true
it's time and there's that moment when
it's like the Rocky song is playing and
you found yourself you're like 100
pounds overweight you go to the gym you
do that one hard workout and then you
look in the mirror the next morning you
kind of look exactly the
same yeah and and I struggle with that
too Dr John I I struggle with what I
call uh the need for uh instant
transformation for instant gratification
there you go you know and I I don't see
the results as fast as I would like to
see that's right and you're coming up on
the holidays holidays gonna be lonely
this time around aren't they I'm I'm I'm
making things uh I'm making plans to
spend a lot of with my kids good dude
I'm so gosh I'm so freaking proud of you
and believe it or not there's one other
thing Dr John what's that uh so Mother's
Day of this past year I actually lost my
mother oh my gosh and I haven't I
haven't even found a way to grieve
her um we had U not not a real strong
relationship towards the end uh there
were some things that happened in the
past with her that I wasn't real proud
of or held against
her and I just haven't I hate to say
this but at the time when she passed I
almost felt relieved yeah hey don't
don't that's that's a very common
response and then you probably felt
guilty for feeling relieved right
absolutely yeah and it just goes in a
circle and so here's a this isn't going
to heal it but this is a good way to
start it's a way to get out of the
starting blocks
okay do you have a pen with you I do
right I do you have to write three
letters to mom over the course of about
three weeks one a week okay okay one of
the letters is how much I miss you
how much I miss you Mom I went through
hell this last year my wife left I lost
my job I'm finally getting sober and
clean and I miss
you I'm always GNA miss you love Jason
and I want that to be a couple of pages
I want you to remember some fun stuff
y'all did as kids how she held it
together after your dad left I want you
to remember some good stuff the second
letter
is unfreaking believable mom
and I want you to tell the truth when I
was a kid you right I want you to go all
the way through the hard stuff the anger
dear Mom I'm really
mad and you know the things that she did
that you held against her that all that
stuff I want you to get that on paper
and here's the third
letter dear Mom I'm sober
now I'm growing up here's what you're
going to
miss you're going to miss watching your
boy Rise From the Ashes you're going to
miss your boy becoming the best dad of
all
time you're going to miss your boy
becoming a success story going to the
gym getting his finances in order
meeting somebody new being the greatest
dad who shows up for his kids and then
being the best Granddad that ever
lived okay yeah I just uh I just had my
um my oldest da just had my second
grandson there you go so I'm I'm I'm
ecstatic about that yes and I don't want
to say this is a chance to do it over
but this is kind of a chance to
reimagine it right absolutely there you
go yep I'd love for you to start writing
that little those two little grandkids
letters so they have 18 years with the
letters from
Granddad okay and let me tell you this
my grandmother passed away a couple
years ago I have tattooed on my arm the
last card she sent me in her handwriting
it says we love
you and I had them lift that that
handwriting and permanently put on my
body that's how much it meant to me that
letter from my
grandmother and I want your grandkids to
have a a a whole thing and when your
grandkids get into some trouble when
they're middle school and high schoolers
which they will I want you to be able to
sit down with them in your 60s and go
hey we're going to Coffee we're going to
pan get pancakes at Waffle House I'm G
I'm going to talk to you about some
stuff I went through and you're going to
redeem your story those bricks you're
carrying around you're G to take them
out of your backpack and set that crap
down it's over and then you're gonna
pave the sidewalks that those kids walk
on on your story see what I'm
saying yes sir this is Legacy
brother this is how you change your
family
tree now I've I've thrown a bunch of
like instagramy stuff at you I'm going
to make it pretty concrete okay is that
cool okay awesome yes here's what I'm
going to do I'm going to load you up but
if I load you up you got to send those
uh you got to send those letters right
absolutely all right I'm gonna send you
both of my Wall Street Journal
bestselling
books you got them you already got them
I've already got them all right I ain't
sending you nothing
then all right so you already got them I
got them I'm gonna send you Financial
Peace University for free I got that too
you got have you used it I'm starting
January all right you can actually do it
yes sir do you have every dollar uh yes
I signed up for all that okay I a giving
you nothing then what do you need what
can I do I I just I guess I just needed
a uh just a voice of
reassurance that's what I
needed what do you really
need just you
know I needed another man to tell me
that I was heading the right direction
Jason you're swimming
Upstream of a culture that tells you
you're washed up a culture that tells
you you're a failure a culture that
tells you ain't worth a
dime you're absolutely worth it every
step you
take are you going to drink again no sir
no sir you got a job I Do I Do It it's a
good job okay we going to hang on to
that
job I'm I'm going to hang on to it but
I'm also uh I'm G to look for something
else that may be a little bit better
okay I I believe in my skills and and
and my knowledge and uh you're gonna be
about you're going to be about serving
the customer taking care of people
solving problems you're gonna do work
with Excellence right absolutely that's
what I do what I do and you're going to
get that debt paid off so you're free
nobody owns Jason right exactly you're
going to write each of your kids a
letter and say hey I wasn't the best dad
but I love you guys and never ever doubt
it I was going through some tough stuff
it was never about you guys and I'm
spending the rest of my life being the
best father that ever
existed yeah you're worth it you're
worth every step of it my
brother every single
step I got something you don't have aha
we're gonna send you grandparents and
grandkids the questions for humans deck
I'm going to mail that out to you and
that way you can chitchat with your
grandkids one of them's gonna be way too
young but you can still chitchat with
them go for that and man I'm so proud of
you dude 52 having to look in the mirror
and start
over a deal with your DUI it's going to
be expensive be honest with the judge
take care of your business there in
Houston don't ever drink and drive don't
put other people at risk you're better
than that don't put you at
risk it's make all the changes let's go
get them 2024 is a year Jason continues
his
journey eight months in for the rest of
your life my brother I'm so proud of
you